¿Hasta qué punto las sanciones que la comunidad
internacional le impuso a Rusia tras la
invasión de Ucrania están funcionando?
Esta es la pregunta, la gran pregunta
que constantemente está sobre la mesa.
Es la masa madre de todo el debate que
gira en torno a la guerra de Ucrania.
¿Y sabéis qué? Vamos a poder encontrar
respuestas para todos los gustos.
Para unos, las sanciones están siendo
un tremendo fracaso. Desde luego,
datos para apoyar su tesis no les faltan:
La maquinaria de guerra rusa no se ha
detenido, el desempleo en el país es bajo,
su economía sigue creciendo y la inflación se
mantiene en niveles razonables de entorno al 5%.
Para otros, en cambio, las sanciones están poco a
poco triturando la capacidad productiva de Rusia.
Por ejemplo, el superávit comercial entre enero
y agosto se desplomó casi un 70% respecto al
año anterior. Esto supone, ni más ni menos, que
una pérdida de más 150 mil millones de dólares.
Lógicamente, al mismo tiempo, los ingresos
petroleros del gobierno también se han
desplomado y el déficit presupuestario ha
dejado de ser una fuente de buenas noticias
para el Kremlin. Por supuesto, la entrada
de inversiones en el país también se está
secando y los viajes al extranjero
son carísimos y están muy limitados.
Un buen reflejo de todo esto lo tenemos
sin ir más lejos en la evolución del rublo.
Pese a todos los controles de capital, la
divisa rusa no deja de caer. Todavía no aspira a
convertirse en una moneda para jugar al Monopoly,
pero el gráfico no es precisamente halagüeño.
Esto es así, básicamente, porque
las fugas de capitales del país
son ya mayores que las entradas de nuevas divisas.
Y eso ni siquiera es todo.
(La constante pérdida de valor del rublo junto con
el incremento del gasto militar han obligado a las
autoridades a tomar medidas. Concretamente, el
banco central ha tenido que subir con fuerza los
tipos de interés para evitar que la inflación se
desboque. Hablamos de tipos que se sitúan ya en
el 12%... Como os podéis imaginar, esta no es
la mejor noticia para familias y empre sarios.
¿El resultado? Entre unas cosas y otras,
Bloomberg sitúa ahora la probabilidad
de que Rusia entre en recesión en
los próximos seis meses en un 21%,
frente al 6% de hace poco más de un mes. La
probabilidad de recesión todavía no es muy alta,
pero la tendencia parece clara:
las cosas se están deteriorando.)
Pero, entonces… ¿Sí que están
funcionando las sanciones?
Pues… Lo cierto es que depende. Amigos,
si hablamos de castigar la maquinaria
de guerra rusa, lo cierto es que no,
no están funcionando mucho. A corto plazo
el golpe para Rusia está siendo limitado.
Pero… Si hablamos de limitar la capacidad
económica y militar del Kremlin,
a largo plazo… Eso ya es otra cosa. Ahí
sí, las sanciones pueden tener mucho éxito.
[Claro que, sea como sea, en este vídeo nuestra
intención no es hablar del mayor o menor daño que
las sanciones están provocando en la economía
rusa. No al menos directamente. De todo eso
ya os hemos hablado recientemente tanto en
nuestro canal hermano, VisualEconomik, como
en Si lo Hubiera Sabido, el canal de información
financiera de Mutuactivos con el que participamos.
Por ejemplo, en este último canal, os
contamos con todo lujo de detalles la
estrategia que el Kremlin está siguiendo para
sortear el embargo comercial que existe sobre
determinados productos. Os dejo el link a este
vídeo de Si lo Hubiera Sabido en la descripción.]
El caso es que en esta ocasión queremos
tocar un tema directamente relacionado
con esta cuestión, pero desde
una perspectiva muy diferente.
Y es que, veréis, un estudio del Instituto
Peterson de Economía Internacional,
ha revelado que las empresas rusas de
energía acumularon durante el 2022 en el
extranjero una especie de fortuna en cuentas
opacas de unos 147 mil millones de dólares.
Además, durante los primeros
6 meses del año este cofre,
podría haberse incrementado en otros 50 mil
millones… En total hablamos en año y medio de
prácticamente 200 mil millones de dólares
que hoy están en manos de gigantes como
Lukoil - la mayor petrolera rusa - o, incluso,
de empresas públicas como Rosneft o Gazprom.
Hablamos de una formidable cantidad de dinero
en divisas internacionales que llegado el caso,
muchos analistas creen que Rusia podría
utilizar para pagar sus esfuerzos de guerra.
Por ejemplo, ¿habéis visto esta noticia?
N1(EE.UU. advierte de que las conversaciones sobre
armamento entre Rusia y Corea del
Norte "avanzan activamente. NBC)
Pues… Quien sabe… Quizás el apoyo de Pyongyang
se pague en gran medida con
dólares del propio Tío Sam.
Ya sabéis que el régimen de Kim Jong-Un
está desesperado por hacerse con dólares…
Entre otras cosas, para pagar los
carísimos caprichos del gran líder.
¿Y sabéis qué? Todo esto tiene mucho
que ver con algunos importantísimos
fallos en las sanciones que se
han aplicado sobre Rusia. Lo que
ha hecho que en VisualPolitik nos
hagamos unas cuantas preguntas.
¿Cómo es posible que las empresas
rusas hayan acumulado semejante
fortuna? ¿Hasta qué punto Rusia
está sorteando las sanciones? ¿Qué
más está haciendo el Kremlin para
esquivar el castigo occidental?
Pues bien… Respondamos a todas estas preguntas.
Vamos con ello.
(HECHA LA LEY HECHA LA TRAMPA)
Amigos, de todas las sanciones impuestas
a Rusia para limitar su capacidad militar,
dos de las más importantes son la congelación de
los activos del banco central en el extranjero,
unos 350 mil millones de dólares, por un
lado; y por otro, el embargo petrolero de
Europa y la fijación del famoso límite de
precio al crudo ruso a nivel internacional.
Pensad que antes de la guerra Rusia era sobre
todo y por encima de todo un gran exportador de
crudo. Ni gas, ni uranio ni armas. La
pasta la daba sobre todo el petróleo.
Bueno, la daba y la sigue dando.
El petróleo y sus derivados son
con mucha diferencia su mayor exportación.
Así que la primera pregunta que podemos
hacernos es, ¿funcionaron las sanciones?
Pues… En principio sí.
(Debido al embargo de la Unión Europea,
los compradores europeos de petróleo ruso
prácticamente han desaparecido. Rusia ha
tenido que canalizar una gran parte de su
crudo hacia otros mercados, algo para lo
que ha tenido que aceptar enormes descuentos.
Esto es algo que se ha contado mil veces.)
De hecho, para intentar frenar
esta sangría, Rusia tuvo que
sumarse al recorte de la producción de
petróleo promovido por Arabia Saudí.
Esto supuso reducir la producción en
cerca de medio millón de barriles al
día justo en un momento en el que Rusia
necesita hasta el último centavo posible.
N2(2 abril 2023: Novak afirma que
Rusia prorrogará hasta finales de
año el recorte de la producción de
petróleo en 500.000 bpd. Reuters)
En principio, la idea del Kremlin, lógicamente,
es que el incremento del precio del petróleo,
como consecuencia de reducir el suministro,
compense la caída en la producción. Pero…
No nos desviemos, que esa es otra historia.
La cuestión es que pese a que los ingresos
petroleros del gobierno se han reducido mucho,
Rusia no solo ha seguido colocando su petróleo,
sino que, además, las grandes compañías rusas
de eee westa industria, entre ellas algunas
empresas públicas como Rosneft o Gazprom,
se han hecho de oro y han acumulado una enorme
fortuna de cerca de 200 mil millones de dólares.
200 mil millones que ahora en gran medida
podrían estar disponibles para el gobierno…
Pero, vale, vayamos paso por paso para entender
esta historia… Para entender por qué,
pese a todas las sanciones aplicadas,
los petrodólares han seguido fluyendo
masivamente de una u otra forma hacia Moscú.
Primero, el embargo europeo sobre el crudo tuvo
algunas excepciones. Hablamos, por ejemplo,
del petróleo ruso que llega a las refinerías
que están conectadas al oleoducto Druzhba,
uno de los oleoductos más grandes del mundo.
Muchas refinerías no tenían alternativas, así
que se permitió que el crudo siguiera fluyendo.
Y aún lo sigue haciendo. Fijaos en el caso,
por ejemplo de la República Checa. En 2021,
el petróleo ruso supuso el 49% de todas sus
importaciones, en 2022 el 56% y en 2023 el 65%.
N3(11 sep 2023: El petróleo ruso
se hace con una mayor porción de
las importaciones checas a pesar del
objetivo de reducir su peso. Reuters)
Supuestamente, están trabajando para revertir
esta situación, pero mientras tanto… money, money.
Y lo mismo ocurrió en Bulgaria, donde la
petrolera rusa Lukoil tenía prácticamente
el monopolio de la industria. Por
este motivo se le concedió permiso
a este país para seguir importando crudo
ruso, incluso por mar durante 2 años más.
Segundo, puede que te sorprenda, pero los
gigantes petroleros rusos como Rosneft o la
propia Lukoil tienen varías refinerías que
son total o parcialmente de su propiedad.
Hablamos de refinerías como la de Zeeland en los
Países Bajos, de la que Lukoil tiene el 45% o
de otras 3 refinerías que esta misma empresa
tiene o tenía en Italia, Bulgaria y Rumanía.
(Pues bien, aquí lo que hicieron fue aprovechar
que el petróleo de los Urales se negociaba muy
barato para abastecer a todas estas refinerías…
Refinerías qué luego vendían su gasolina,
diesel y demás derivados a precios de mercado
de Europa, precio que estaban por las nubes.
Esto explica por qué algunos países como Italia o
Bulgaria duplicaron durante meses
sus compras de petróleo ruso.)
El margen era gigantesco… Para que os hagáis
una idea, si normalmente una refinería tiene
un margen de 10 dólares al convertir un
barril de petróleo en un combustible,
en estas refinerías el margen se multiplicó
hasta situarse entre 40 y 50 dólares.
De repente, estas instalaciones se
convirtieron en auténticas minas de oro.
Si hubiera una lista 'Forbes' de refinerías,
¡estas estarían sin duda en la portada!"
Eran superrentables. Lo que hizo que sus
propietarios rusos hicieran una increíble
fortuna. Hablamos de una enorme
montaña de euros y de dólares que
luego las empresas rusas se cuidaron
mucho de esconder a lo largo y ancho
de todo el mundo a través de un montón
de filiales y compañías superpuestas.
[Vamos el 'tour mundial'
del escondite financiero.]
De hecho, en este gráfico podéis ver el suministro
de petrolero ruso a Europa durante 2022. Aunque
la llegada total de crudo se redujo, no se redujo
el petróleo directamente comprado por filiales de
las propias empresas rusas, o el del oleoducto
que abastece a Hungría y la República Checa.
Eso sí, todo sea dicho. Alemania,
por ejemplo, terminó expropiando dos
refinerías propiedad de Rosneft y Gazprom.
Pero durante un tiempo hicieron mucha caja.
Luego otras instalaciones se han vendido
en tratos… que en muchos casos, bueno,
que os voy a contar… Digamos que los
rusos saben poner su dinero a cubierto.
El caso es que de esta forma es como Rusia
ha logrado un montón de divisas. Recordad
que el gobierno y el banco central tienen
restringidas sus operaciones de reserva
en dólares y en euros… Sin embargo,
no ocurre lo mismo con las empresas,
públicas o privadas. En otras palabras, que
estamos ante una especie de trampolín petrolero.
De hecho, os hago una pregunta:
¿cuánto dinero se le congeló a
Rusia? Unos 300 mil millones de
dólares en divisas extranjeras.
Y… ¿Cuánto han almacenado las petroleras en apenas
año y medio? 200 mil millones. Vale, todavía no
lo han compensado, pero Putin ya tiene todos los
dólares que necesita para lo que de la real gana.
¿Importar chips vía Kazajistán, tal vez?
¿Quizás Importar maquinaria moderna vía
Armenia? ¿O pagar a Corea del Norte por
sus toneladas de munición? Lo que sea.
Sí, vale, es cierto, este dinero no es
estrictamente del gobierno… pero ¡Qué
diantres! Hablamos de Rusia. Todo gira en torno
al Kremlin. Recordad que hablamos de un país
donde el gobierno llegó a montarse su propio
ejército privado. Así que de una forma u otra
no dudéis que en Moscú encontrarán la fórmula
para utilizar todo este imperio, su antojo.
Pero, queridos, amigos, amigas,
eso no es todo. Que el río de
dólares haya seguido fluyendo
hacia Rusia tiene más motivos.
(En tercer lugar, Rusia ha buscado otros
mercados para colocar su petróleo. Hemos
hablado de ellos un montón de veces.
Nos referimos a países como China,
la India o, incluso, algunas repúblicas africanas.
La cuestión es que hablamos de países
que no se sumaron directamente al tope
de precio establecido por el G-7,
la Unión Europea y Australia.)
Pero quizás aquí lo más llamativo… No es que
estos países no se sumaran a ese acuerdo,
sino que el plan de occidente tampoco no
parece haberse aplicado particularmente bien.
¿A qué me refiero? Pues… Veréis…
Según varías estimaciones,
durante los primeros 6 meses del 2023, cerca
de la mitad de todas las exportaciones rusas
desde los puertos del Pacífico, donde el
precio de venta superó el límite fijado,
se hicieron en barcos que eran propiedad
o estaban asegurados por compañías de
países que sí habían suscrito el límite.
Hablamos, sobre todo, de Grecia. Fijaos.
N4(17 abril 2023: Los griegos dominan las
exportaciones rusas de petróleo. Según Vortexa,
una empresa de análisis de datos, la
flota de petroleros que participa en
el comercio ruso tras las sanciones está operada
predominantemente por griegos: World Energy Trade)
Para que os hagáis una idea
de lo que estamos hablando,
tan solo en los 4 primeros meses del
2023 estas empresas transportaron o
aseguraron el transporte de más de 40
mil millones de dólares de crudo ruso.
Es decir, que de una forma u otra
no se ha hecho todo lo posible.
Sí, la idea del límite de precio
es que el petróleo ruso siguiera
fluyendo en el mercado mundial, pero
que lo hiciera a un precio limitado.
Y eso, eso solo se ha conseguido parcialmente.
Claro que esto nos lleva directamente
a una cuestión absolutamente clave.
Amigos, ¿Os habéis dado cuenta? Todas
estas compañías son ahora absolutamente
imprescindibles para Moscú. Ya no se trata
solo de si venden más o menos crudo. La
cuestión es que ahora también atesoran
el cofre de la riqueza nacional rusa.
¿Y sabéis qué significa esto? Que si
a medio plazo se encontraran fuentes
alternativas y suficientes de crudo se podría ir
directamente contra las petroleras rusas… Y eso,
eso sí que podría ser un
golpe terrible para Rusia.
Y la pregunta es, ¿es que acaso
no saben esto en Moscú? Pues sí,
evidentemente lo saben. Pero es lo que hay.
Eso sí, por lo que pueda pasar, la estrategia
ahora para contrarrestar esa posibilidad
pasa fundamentalmente por tres caminos:
Primero que estas empresas escondan
todo lo que puedan el dinero.
Segundo, hacer lo que ya están
haciendo con el comercio:
utilizar más las divisas de países
aliados. Desde 2022, por ejemplo,
el peso del dólar y del euro en el comercio ruso
ha caído del 80% a menos del 50%. Pues bien,
probablemente con gran parte de las reservas de
los gigantes petroleros ocurra algo similar. Es
decir, que pronto veremos un montón de
inversiones rusas fuera de occidente.
Y tercero, para intentar al menos limitar
el déficit público, están aprobando reformas
legales para que estos gigantes contribuyan más
a las arcas públicas. Hasta ahora, por ejemplo,
los impuestos a la producción de petróleo
estaban referenciados al precio de cotización
del crudo de los Urales, de ahí que sus
ingresos cayeran tanto tras la fijación
del tope al precio del petróleo. Sin embargo,
desde entonces han ido cambiando las normas.
De esta forma, el margen de actuación de
Moscú será mayor. Esto explica de hecho
por qué los números del presupuesto
han mejorado en los últimos meses.
Luego, junto a todas estas técnicas relacionadas
con el petróleo, está lo que Alberto ya nos contó
en Si lo Hubiera Sabido. Estoy hablando
de la conocida como rotonda euroasiática.
Rusia está utilizando a países del entorno para
saltarse las restricciones internacionales.
Este es el caso, por ejemplo, de Armenia.
Las exportaciones de este pequeño país del
Cáucaso, de apenas 2,7 millones de habitantes,
a Rusia se han multiplicado por 4. Al mismo
tiempo, sus compras a la Unión Europea, Estados
Unidos, Reino Unido o Japón se han triplicado.
¿Sabéis lo que significa verdad? Pues eso.
Entre unas cosas y otras, seguro que ahora
podéis entender por qué los restaurantes
de Moscú siguen llenos, porque los
centros comerciales no parecen haber
sufrido grandes cambios y porque las
cosas aparentemente no van tan malo.
Sin embargo… Un momento, que nadie se engañe.
Todo esto que hemos visto en este vídeo
son trucos, trampas, estrategias con las
que Putin se ha saltado las sanciones… Pero a
largo plazo la economía rusa sufrirá y mucho.
Todos estos productos que llegan ahora al país
son mucho más caros, la inversión extranjera
va a estar hundida por mucho tiempo y los
jóvenes profesionales harán todo lo posible
por escapar del país. Primero para tener futuro
y segundo para evitar ser llamados a filas. A la
larga todo esto afectará y mucho a sus ya de
por sí desastrosos niveles de productividad.
Pero por ahora Putin está sobreviviendo.
La pregunta, ¿Qué pensáis que deberían hacer los
aliados occidentales de Ucrania? ¿Deberían tomarse
este tema más en serio? ¿Perseguiríais los activos
de las empresas públicas a lo largo y ancho
del mundo? ¿De qué forma creéis que se podría
castigar de verdad el esfuerzo de guerra de Moscú?
Como siempre dejadnos ideas por aquí abajo. Y
como ya es tradición, el legendario de credo de
los creadores de YouTube: Ya sabéis, si
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante,
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si es que aun no lo habéis hecho.
Gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.